I don't think it's reasonable to expect
the candidates for public office are
going to have good solutions to the
crisis of integrity in our life and it's
in a public life and it's not because
politicians can't have integrity of
course they can I don't dump on
politicians the way some people do it's
because it's not a problem the
government can fix it's a problem that
we have to decide to fixing our private
lives I would like to see candidates
talk more about poverty but I worry a
lot that Democratic Republican
candidates a like is it male is a club
together over the head it's not so much
what they're committed to in their
campaigns in a serious way it's more a
tool for making other people look bad
it's really unfortunate if you look at
the trends for example in the black
community the the trend toward income
stratification that is the the well do
by people getting better off in the
worse off pilgrim worse off that's
gotten worse under the bush ministration
got worse under the clinton istration
it's just been getting worse for years
it's not a left right thing it's just
been getting worse and getting worse
than getting worse most of the trends
there's some that are on an uptick most
the trends in the black community that
are troubling and that are going in the
wrong direction have been going in the
wrong direction for a long time so it's
not a matter of which party is in power
is that it takes more to fix them
there's a need for public solutions
there's need for some policies there's
also natural private solutions need for
people to try to fix some things from
within as well I'm not terribly sanguine
about our willing stew are the one of
those things I'm not terribly sign what
about are willing to do the things that
will cost money in the public sector I'm
not we'll terribly sanguine about our
ability to encourage marriage which
might cost people ideological points um
and if we can't do those things that I
know what the future is for these
problems I honestly don't know what it
is we're going to do and understand what
I say poverty I mean it's am absolute
sense i don't mean I don't care in
America if rich people get really rich I
don't care about who's got the most
money
I minish to the people at the other end
it's not that oh goodness rich peel of
money the poor people don't understand
why that is the reason for building
money because rich people have money or
is there some other reason it's
important to know why poor people are
suffering t able to fix their suffering
and I think too often we guess at why
they're suffering and sometimes we guess
wrong sounds I guess wrong and yet
sometimes there are some problems that
could be not repair it's only helped
long could spend more money and I wish
we would but not every probably helped
along that way
hey